[Music]
it may only be an hour outside of
manhattan
but the quiet town of cranberry new
jersey feels like it's thousands of
miles away
in this historic village is a little
french bistro called hannah and mason's
friends chris and brian were co-workers
here under the previous owners and
jumped at the opportunity to buy the
restaurant three years ago can we get
serious now all right come on focus
focus i was afraid from the beginning to
take the restaurant oh what the [ __ ] am
i doing this
i was also a little short of cash so i
figured brian knew the operation
we worked together already and he had
the other half of the cash we could do
this we could do this
but looking back no i don't think i
would go into business with brian this
was a mistake
i'm very laid back and i i don't think i
let a lot of things bother me all right
you suck whatever
brian's very lazy
brian can be lazy brian needs to step up
a lot i just find it difficult to be
motivated
that's just how i've always been
and i find it difficult to change
when your heart's not in it why doesn't
anybody else be in it why i agree my
partnership with brian is
not equal enough enough for this [ __ ]
please i generally pay most of the bills
i spent a good portion of the day
ordering food doing prep lists working
on menus generally i'll work the line
for most dinners
brian why are you clean hold on
i don't particularly like to work the
nights so we're only open three nights a
week for dinner done there's no more to
be had i really don't think we're losing
out on any business
[Music]
there's nobody here
people call and they ask you know can i
come in on tuesday and
no we're not open and you can't bring in
the customers you can't bring in the
money
we're having a very tough time making
ends meet it has been increasingly more
and more stressful to come in and look
at how much we owe money to and the
bills are piling up and it's it's a
little too much stress for me all right
this pretty much sucks hopefully we make
some money tonight
i go to try to deposit my paycheck in
the bank and i can't because there's no
money
i get sick of how much money we spend on
bounds check fees it's it's a horrible
feeling oh my gosh
if hannah mason's ever had to close
i would be lost because i wouldn't be
able to support my daughter
you know for me it's a career i don't
know anything else i don't want to
really know anything else
trying to hold out for hope if it goes
that much longer i don't know what i'm
going to do
[Music]
what a beautiful quaint little town i
can't think of a better way to spend
valentine's day at hannah and mace mesa
i guess i couldn't afford the end that's
not a good start
right here we go
hello hi how are you good follow me
okay excellent fine lovely i thought you
are nick hello yes okay great nice to
meet you good to see you too and yeah
what do you do i'm the manager
young i'm very young yes i'm only 23
years old and i bust my ass day in and
day out
chris yes he's sitting down he's very
cute
when i saw him walk through the door and
i says oh my gosh look at this man
this is marie she's gonna pick her up
happy valentine's day awesome is this a
picture of your wife no that's my dear
lady yes can i see oh please yeah that's
the 14th valentine's day we haven't been
together
she's beautiful thank you my darling
can't wait to taste the food i would
suggest
just to start off with the baked onion
soup right are you asking me or telling
me
if you want my suggestion baked i need
to let's go for that shall we okay um
the quiche nice occasion okay thank you
um i'm fascinated by the lamb lollipops
okay
lovely thank you you're welcome
well there's stuff like this soup that's
for sure
we're gonna start with onion soup okay
some people might say oh french onion
soup is french onion soup is french
onion soup but i think ours have a
distinct you know presentation
wow
let's start off with zero out of ten for
presentation
lovely
greasy
[Music]
kate with cheese
[Music]
kate with bread the only thing missing
is the soup
what is that in there
that's absolutely tasteless
it tastes like i've just had the dregs
from the dishwasher
hardly any soup that is shocking
that was very different
um
once you got rid of all the bread and
the cheese and the gunk it's just okay
very very bland but i'll bypass and
hopefully the uh
lamb lollipop will be tasty
thank you
fine dining
a fine mess
and he didn't like this
[Music]
off to a great start ladies and
gentlemen
once he got past all the the gunk with
the bread he said that growth was just
bland and he's never experienced
anything like that before he's never
experienced anything as amazing as that
we've gotten you know fairly good
reviews here so i find it hard to
believe that it's really as bad as he
says
say something chris get mad chris won't
chris get pissed
ugh
this is not gonna go good because if i
can't get him with the french onion i
can't nothing's gonna be good
wow
that is a big big lollipop
my goodness
me is an absolute nightmare to to cut
undercooked
it's hideous chris no matter what
anybody says i still think you have the
best on youtube and the best lamb if he
talks [ __ ] about the lamb he's he's out
of his mind it's completely ridiculous
that's sauce there that's hideous
it's like a caramel as sweet as anything
very um what did you say that was a
roasted garlic jam god nick would you
little taste that it's like someone's
put a topping of a granulated sugar
caramel although gordon didn't like the
lamb all the employees and all the
customers think that that's our best
dish very sweet the sugar suddenly the
lamb is raw and it's obviously cold in
the middle because it hasn't rested okay
let's uh let's go with the quiche
uh
darling you've got to turn away now i
don't want to see you
facing that [ __ ] any longer
absolutely appalling you said he ordered
a rare not raw
and the sauce was a spoonful of sugar
so chris why did that go out like that
where's my car keys you got to go out
there next time he says something hey
yeah i will i will
sort of sound like my wife you're
cowering
whatever i don't know chris is
definitely scared of somebody telling
him his dishes aren't good enough it
frustrates me as a manager because he
needs to put his foot down sometimes
here possibly my dying they're going to
be saving the best for last
lovely and what flavor quiche is it it
is mushroom spinach mushroom spinach
lovely thank you you're welcome
damn
my quiche has collapsed it's gone into
like this sort of meltdown
it's almost like it's been left out
of the refrigeration all day and that's
for the salad well
you do
you really notice all the ends of the
salads are all black
hmm
i have a feeling i'm getting yelled at
already
they sort of collapsed and went all sort
of uh runny and soggy i'm sorry huh
happy valentine's day
thank you
oh good now he cut into it and it just
collapsed and it's all gooey inside
the customers mostly have good things to
say so it's a little shocking to hear
someone say that almost everything that
we served in was horrible
[Music]
this quaint village had put gordon in a
pleasant state of mind his name is chris
chris and where's the brigade
unfortunately the food destroyed it this
is my partner brian ryan
i'm not really nervous to meet chef
ramsay you know he thought everything
was gross but
whatever okay
lunch was hideous
it's really important before we go
anywhere i need to know the
foundation
how many nights a week are you cooking
well we're only open three nights a week
for dinner
are you having three nights a week why
being ridiculously cautious and fearful
and the way i've led my entire life he
played safe yes sir but sending those
kind of messages out to the local
community that you're closed longer than
you're open it's telling the locals
you're closed
if he wasn't here what's his weak points
he doesn't have a love or a passion for
the business itself how come you're
passionate and you're not we're just
different people
a business is a business
yeah it's a restaurant yes i love to
cook but it would be easier sometimes
just not to own a restaurant when was
the last time you made a decision
i made a special what was it
turkey panini
turkey panini right
i'm just
i don't know what you're looking for
passion
strong will determination you look like
you're just about to lose your virginity
sorry
something needs to happen the relight
this flame
now i'm gonna see how you operate it
okay let's see in two minutes
right now i am absolutely unfocused for
dinner
i'm gonna be thinking everything i send
out is as [ __ ] unbelievable
all right let's just get focused and
let's get ready for dinner cause
dinner's gonna be off debacle
gordon was shocked to find out that
hannah and mason's is closed more than
it's open but this is valentine's day a
day when all restaurants are busy this
is our special valentine's day menu and
a great opportunity for him to observe a
dinner service
okay
so we have two tables upstairs right
how many people do we have coming in in
the immediate future i knew that going
into valentine's day and knowing that
chef ramsay was going to be overseeing
everything that was happening i was
definitely a bit nervous
dude
it's uh
is that ready to go out there no sir
display purposes only
seriously what the [ __ ] is
that that's apple cowboy when was that
made
well anyone's guessed jeff i mean not
more than a week ago and holy [ __ ]
that's a uh
a molten lava cake a molten lava cake no
a molten rock lava rock so what'd you do
with that
well
do you play ice hockey no that's again
display purposes only right off the bat
we were in the ships right off the bat
why would we even think about going
to a customer with something a week old
oh we should thank you chris
brian yes
no that doesn't look good at all i agree
yeah
it's disgusting yeah hello get rid of it
okay yeah
as tensions mount in the kitchen
customers are about to celebrate one of
the most romantic nights of the year
happy valentine's day
[Music]
[Music]
come
[Music]
i think after the first day i would just
leave and never come back i wouldn't
care if i didn't get him paid
chef ramsay telling me that you know we
do things the wrong way it just doesn't
really work for me
oh my god
ryan yes two seconds
and your liking shuts up
who's checking this stuff does this guy
just send food out yeah but who's
checking it
nobody's nobody no okay
there's lettuce all [ __ ] rotten there
yeah lettuce rotten there
first we gotta pick through the lettuce
better
i really am trying to like i'm not even
these ones are no good with the rotten
lettuce let's just go oh [ __ ] wait
where's this coming from
jesus christ the mighty
sir has it been washed i did not watch
that i do not know we don't wash spinach
we get pre-washed you get it pre-washed
that's the first
oh look every time i dig my hand in it
it's all wrong they're just dudes you
toss it yeah it's great i won't toss it
why don't you eat it i'd rather not yeah
well then i wouldn't need it you'd
charge people
okay there you go you shouldn't this
shouldn't be sent out no you should open
me [ __ ] eyes we'll try to fix
whatever issues we have but i can't i'm
not gonna cry in the corner about it you
know life goes on
so upon further investigation oh my gosh
gordon discovers that something is
missing from the display only dessert
tray we serve that dessert on there
yeah
here we
are that dessert's been served from that
that's not good what's this here
it's been leaking in the fridge
that's really old it's a bread pudding
that's a bread pudding sure that's a
shrimp
[ __ ] it
it's not
yeah that's disgusting
why is it bubbling
because it's old
[Music]
i know you're busy yeah i'm [ __ ]
[ __ ] myself now i feel when you know
things aren't going good i i just assume
get out you know just move on to the
next thing hey where's brian
i know you want to run away from it i'm
not running i can't run away from it
yeah i've just been watching and [ __ ]
[ __ ] myself for the last hour
what are you doing to people
give me an answer
[Music]
you know we can't oversee everything we
assume that okay
take me down to the fridge i want to see
how you [ __ ] really work
i cannot believe
that this is how you guys are running a
restaurant in my head i was thinking
we're gonna be screwed that's what in
there
that's the walk-in freezer freezer
that's a walk-in freezer look at the
mess here what's this here
bacon
yeah obviously bacon smells that's from
lunch
yeah yeah five years ago
you leave a spatula in there like that
i'm sorry no [ __ ] off
i cannot believe
what you guys are doing here
there's so much going on my head was
spinning my head was going to explode i
i thought to myself this is a disaster
what's that in there
[ __ ] that didn't get put over
oh my god i don't know
oh my god
oh no
[Music]
this is not good raw chicken that should
never happen you know
oh my god chris is [ __ ] chicken
against raw chicken it's it's [ __ ]
hey panini head are you listening to me
yes you're gonna kill someone
i'm eating here
partners
partners in crime
you should be ashamed we are insane
you've just contaminated the town
and nick nick
stop
yeah everybody
right now
this is not a romantic detail this is a
valentine [ __ ] massacre
it's a disgrace
how can you do this
i'm closing the place down
switch it off
it's valentine's day the busiest night
of the year for restaurants but what the
customers don't realize is that some
shocking discoveries left gordon with no
other choice but to shut it down switch
it off
what's going to tell the people i tell
them
you tell me then what we're gonna tell
them or you think i'm gonna stand here
and watch you serve contaminated food no
yeah yeah [ __ ] shut it down switch it
off and condemn it
i knew that we were gonna monitor some
problems tonight i didn't know it was
gonna be this bad
mark turn everything off that's it we're
done
no one touches or serves any food right
all the way down
i suggest you start coming up with some
suggestions of customers yeah yes sir
yeah
hurry up brian
um jeff ramsay is shutting us down i
feel absolutely horrible and uh
certainly not something i expected
just just really
never in my wildest dreams thinking that
we would have to shut down
[Music]
this is the most horrific thing i've
ever had to deal with in my life quite
frankly that felt horrible
[Music]
what i've just
discovered is totally unacceptable
enough's enough
chris yes sir if you are passionate
about food and you feel deeply about it
i want to hear it i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready to tear it down and start over
you've got a big pair of balls facing
those customers tonight
what they can say for the partner that
you are in business with where were you
how many tables did you talk to
how many customers do you apologize to
how much support did you give the
waitresses the manager
that's right you were doing jack [ __ ]
mate
i do feel like i carry the bulk of the
restaurant oh it absolutely bothers me
that brian doesn't take on some of those
things make me sick
unbelievable
on a night when they should have been
busy serving the staff finds itself
cleaning up the mess i don't even know
where to start i mean i never really
thought i'd be in this situation i'm
really trying to see the light at the
end of the tunnel i'm trying to hold out
for hope
oh my god
of course i'm worried this is my life
i need those customers to come back
[Music]
before gordon unveils his plan for
change he explores the town of cranberry
looking for inspiration
this whole town is built up on farms
perfect position to have a local
restaurant wow amazed by the number of
local farms in the area gordon decides
to check out the seasonal produce hi
ladies huh sorry welcome to terry and
orchards we're glad to have you it's
beautiful thank you absolutely amazing
just driving around locally and just
looking at some of the farm i mean it's
a chef's dream
we pick everything every day amazing and
in terms of variety of apples how many
do you have here we grow 35 different
kanya
pretty good crunch there mmm delicious
brian should i uh just help myself your
favorite fill it in excellent
lovely look at the size of these
great
that is amazing now i'm gonna put these
to good use excellent what are you gonna
make oh a secret you're gonna have to
come for dinner all right we're
available thank you
inspired by the fresh locally grown
apples chef ramsay heads back to the
restaurant to work on a special he has
in mind for tonight's dinner service
right
what are they called apples
[ __ ] smalls you asked me what they
were they're apples yeah no it's the way
you say it with no excuses if i want to
learn to cook like you i'll definitely
buy your cookbook
but
this it's just not for me why are you in
business running a restaurant when
you're completely passion-less about
talking about ingredients it's a [ __ ]
apple yes they're local apples that's
great okay when was the last time you
tasted one
it's been a while i haven't been to the
local orchard to get an apple tarou farm
well i've been there for the last two
hours okay
it's like being around your parents when
they're arguing and it's the most
uncomfortable thing in the world and now
i hated it
yeah it's a good apple you don't get it
dude i do let it then delicious
and so talking to you about it it's like
oh really it's an apple yes one a day
keeps the doctor away am i supposed to
jump up and down no not at all it's just
becoming clearly evident that you are
incredibly soulless when it comes to
food you're entitled to your opinion
if chef gordon keeps pushing me i just
won't be here anymore you won't see me
today
as brian cools off okay apple's in
gordon teaches chris a new special
everything has to be relaxed pork
medallions with caramelized braeburn
apples and then just finish
with a hint of the mustard yeah yeah
hoping to put the valentine's day
massacre behind them the staff gears up
for dinner service
and takes advantage of the local produce
[Music]
are we are we ready to go yes yeah okay
guys let's go let's get them in
i have no problems about leaving i feel
bad for you guys but there's no way if
he starts him with that [ __ ] again i
will [ __ ] do you let the bloodbath
begin
i'm gonna do the best to get brian more
focused for dinner brian why don't you
show me your passion and lead the
brigade tonight sure it's fine that's
fine
that sounded enthusiastic didn't it
i don't feel like i need to prove
anything to him i mean i am who i am and
what are you going to do
especially we have sauteed pork
medallions i will have the filet mignon
harvest salad you fire the entrees on
table five what's that stuff uh brian
what's up what's western what's going on
i'm running around trying to get all
this stuff together
um
with uh five tickets on the board
is it worth getting something going
[Music]
brian it's a very quiet kitchen normally
it's quiet we don't tend to yell and
shout out so how do you guys know what's
going on when no one's talking to each
other we haven't said anything
i guess i'm not running it then
nothing makes me angry at night getting
served in the restaurant
look at this service brian tommy's gonna
run the kitchen and run it with some
passion but so far i don't see it i
don't feel it and the kitchen is backed
up customers are complaining about
waiting and i don't think brian actually
gives a [ __ ]
i'm just waiting for myself which one
102 still okay i'll get it 102 how long
two minutes three minutes four
i'm not really sure
i don't mean wait 15 minutes 15 minutes
dude this is taking forever trying
to tell nick to slow down the orders or
what he should know i mean we shouldn't
have to tell him he could tell that
we're backed up oh my god come on
brian is not putting in enough effort it
makes me frustrated he needs to step up
more
i feel pressured when someone's watching
me and telling me i can't do it but i
don't need him here yelling at me that's
not going to make me want to work any
harder your lack of excitement and
passion bugs me
i'm struggling to come to terms while
you're in business i'm not like you i i
can't get excited it's not what you're
doing to me you've got to understand
that it's what you're doing to the
business the business for me is the
bigger picture i'm not here to massage
your ego i'm really sorry customers are
complaining about waiting doesn't that
mean anything to you i just felt like i
was being picked on
whatever panini had i'm worried about
how much you're putting the business
down but you won't accept that because
you can't be honest with yourself
because i'm not oh you're being a dick
about it what am i being a dick about
me just the way you talk don't run down
the stairs like a little girl no i'm
gonna i'm talking to you you don't talk
to people that's your problem calling
people at nene head no cool
that's like [ __ ] sixth grade how
[ __ ] old are you i don't need someone
to tell me
you know talk to me like that i'm past
that point in my life it's just
ridiculous enough
it's an hour into dinner service and
brian has threatened to leave the
restaurant
with no food leaving the kitchen
everything is at a standstill
don't you think i don't think he's gonna
walk out tonight yes he will i don't
he's on the verge right now he just says
he gives it another hour he says it for
himself he keeps taking it to him he's
leading
brian they get a little frustrated with
chef ramsay and i don't know what's
going through brian's head right now if
i didn't give a [ __ ] you know i would
have left a long time ago i'm dedicated
to this place because i want to be here
i want to do this i want i want to make
it work all i want is just for you to
show a little bit of interest
if i wasn't interested i wouldn't be
here i wouldn't be doing this right in
my heart i really i do care maybe i
don't show it all the time and i should
but i definitely need to show that i
have more interest than what i'm
perceived to have great let's go
[Music]
okay here we
are i'm sorry about the weight i
apologize
hit the bell please
wow keep going yes that is going
table break table three table three
all right thank you so
thank you
we started pumping things out took a
little bit while in the beginning but
once we got going it went over pretty
well thank you have a good one
good news tonight is that the special
sold out yes yeah great news
brian you're smiling for the first time
since i met you
i'm changing right now i mean i need to
be able to have a positive attitude all
the time let me tell you something
really seriously honestly
if you actually think this restaurant in
this community is going to be here in
five years time when you're mediocre
bang we know that you know we have to do
something different to
make the business grow thank you
you're absolutely spot on we have to be
special and we have to cook
locally i think the products we had
today were excellent so it would be good
to you know put a lot of that into our
menu that's what we have to change yes
tomorrow we're gonna revamp the whole
[ __ ] place
i think we need a change but i'm nervous
scared tomorrow morning this place
becomes the crown jewel within cranberry
i really don't know what to expect is
that clear
sounds good is there anyone here that's
not fired up
okay
let's do it
with brian finally on board chef ramsay
moves forward transforming hannah and
masons from a dreary bistro into a
delightful cafe
[Music]
all right good morning good morning
excited extremely excited i've got your
name
[Music]
happy with the end yes
now it's time to open a new chapter
behind the masons let's go
[Music]
i almost
fell on the floor oh my god i just
couldn't believe how great it looked
when we walked in a new deli counter
showcasing local fresh products
we didn't just renovate this place
we changed the meaning of it
the breads the homemade cupcakes
everything made locally i like it local
farms share the pride and you show it
off this place can become synonymous
with these farms
it's got synergy there oh my god
it's amazing is the happiest i've ever
seen you
if this doesn't really like your fight i
don't know what will i'm glad chef
ramsay came and you know he made these
changes it's amazing it really is and
i'm hoping that you know it makes our
business all the better
beautiful
i think i'm in shock the restaurant is
gone i just don't know you don't know oh
no you change your mind i don't know
it's a complete the hannah mason's
closed last night anna mason's bakery
and cafe opened today i just don't know
going far it's i mean i mean everyone's
afraid of the unknown i knew there was
going to be changes but this is a
complete departure from what we've done
hannah mason didn't close last night
we've just changed we changed completely
it's oh it's overwhelming embrace change
just being a realist you're not being a
realist you're being pessimistic
chef ramsay obliterated hannah and
masons as it was and it's not going to
work
[Music]
gordon has revealed that the new
hannahan masons will be an upscale cafe
and no longer a french bistro but not
everyone is comfortable with the change
embrace change just being a realist
you're not being a realist you're being
pessimistic great
okay we'll go through the menu
previously the menus two menus before
lunch and dinner absolutely crazy you've
got no idea how simple this is fine
dining has gone
yes it's small but it's powerful
fresh vibrant rustic countrified cuisine
ryan i'm ready let's get started to see
what all this stuff looks like
chris
look at that face
i just read and just reading the menu
thinking in my head it's different it's
it's definitely different
why don't you ask me here
this is because we needed a kick in the
ass this uh jeff this is it's just
things going through my head that's all
i even well
let's see chris is really nervous to
make the change
just for the fear of losing business
that we have yesterday
here you stand me today you're shocking
me because i'm shocked oh my god i need
to get my hands in it
[Music]
while gordon had the staff focusing on
the new menu his team put together a
farmer's market an event to showcase the
new relationship between hannah and
masons and the local farm community
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you sir let's go hi guys
good morning how are you right no
ah fantastic
awesome so we've got some tastes of
olives you got some scones get the staff
involved and uh make sure all these
menus go off as well yes
hello everybody a little chilly out
today let's go
right fly's giving out a little taste
let's go so this is our new menu we're
reaching out to the community it's going
to flourish our business to a whole new
level you know you got to see it it's
beautiful
the new menu looks really good it looks
great
hi my name is how are you
congratulations thank you
yes it is thank you it's great for me to
meet the local farmers i love the idea
of using locally i hope you enjoyed our
apple we did they were awesome well
let's see if we can work something out
so you can use more local produce
yep we are going to absolutely do that
great i hope that people are going to be
happy that we're using low growers and
people are always happy about that and
you taste it you definitely taste the
difference there's no doubt about that
after a successful farmer's market
gordon introduces the new menu a menu
created to take full advantage of all
that the local farms have to offer let's
show you the menu yes first of all just
look at the color of it
it uses what
vibrancy freshness the dishes you can
recognize easily the ribeye sandwich
smoked chicken salad beef hash with eggs
entrees a really nice uh winter
free-range chicken stew
the lamb burger
very short ribs our fish today is going
to be the swordfish
yeah i like a lot of the items and i
like the menu and i like the simplicity
of it but i think there's going to be a
learning curve any questions no no no
excellence
did you see the sign it's hannah and
mason it's not hannah and mesos all
right come on in we're right here we
have a couple changes to our menu as you
can see the chef's special today is a
grilled swordfish served with tarragon
mashed potatoes this morning i thought
brian would be really anti any form of
change but he's actually embraced it
quite well but chris he's been on off
the train all day long and the jury's
out as far as i'm concerned on him but
tonight we'll find out who really wants
to turn this place around it's an
interesting launch
gordon knows that in order for hannah
and masons to make a profit they must
successfully flip tables and have two
complete seatings
chris yeah chef we have to flip tables
tonight
what does that mean make your money i
know you're not used to it hey but we've
got to do it yeah oh yes yeah i don't
feel like i'm in control at all for
what's gonna happen this evening not
until the tickets start rolling and it's
just the anticipation at this point i
think the special sounds really good
though
the swordfish
[Music]
first order well done yeah brian one cop
sell it away please
okay level four is up gently gently good
nice
two and twenty gone brian
uh yeah yeah
first course on 23 just went
this tastes homemade
[Music]
that was a joke yes it was
[Music]
i've never seen any moves so quick you
want
let me just check yeah i'm a former guy
i'm alive i got a pulse no no just it's
moving yeah huh
surely there must be a difference inside
here
with brian rising to the occasion and
getting appetizers out promptly
yes it is now up to chris to deliver the
entrees so that the next round of
customers can be seated shortly next
table uh right now nothing else fires
nothing else give me nick please
anything about to be fired anything
happening or
got a turn chris
he's killing me i said you're killing me
uh nick we're pulling behind all yes i
think we are falling
[Music]
unbelievable last night the appetizers
took 20 minutes to come out tonight
they're only taking 12 but that's not
the problem the problem is the entrees
aren't coming out quick enough the
customers are staying at the table's
longer and we need to flip those tables
if you've got any chance of surviving
get some tables up get some tables up
all right yeah with a queue at the door
now we've got to push these tables out
come on what are you waiting for marie
game of four table four yeah
open up buddy let's go next come on you
got backing up with tickets you got to
talk to these two guys someone needs
direction here a little bit i'm going on
a salmon and crab and a swordfish so i
need mashed potatoes please
the 86 match unless we got some
somewhere else having run out of mashed
potatoes chris makes a very telling
decision not gonna be serving mashed
potatoes on the uh swordfish anymore
[Music]
we were running low on mashed potatoes
um and i didn't think it would be a big
deal to sum something out i'm thinking
in my head i don't want this to get
backed up then the whole house of cards
falls can't we put potatoes on chris i
mean by the time we get them peeled and
gonna put them on
it might be tomorrow oh here we go
it's just excuse after excuse me excuse
you you own the [ __ ] place yeah yeah
you damn so you want to tell the [ __ ]
customers we can't be bothered to make a
[ __ ] mashed potato we can sum
something out i just find it
embarrassing why can't we said take it
out
and we could sub something out just too
easy ah [ __ ] it do the easy route yeah
turn the [ __ ] off we can't be bothered
anymore you're the bar chef
that's [ __ ]
[Music]
it's the heart of dinner service and in
an effort to keep up with the orders
it's not turning those tables there now
yes
chris decides to cut corners i'm not
gonna be serving mashed potatoes on the
uh swordfish anymore oh here we go
we were running low on mashed potatoes
um and i didn't think it would be a big
deal to sub something out i'm thinking
in my head i don't want this get backed
up then the whole house of cards falls
just too easy all right [ __ ] it do the
easy route yeah tell them to [ __ ] off we
can't be bothered anymore you're the
boss chef
that's [ __ ] all you need to do is
peel half of the potatoes we get them
all
peel some potatoes please
i've tried to make it as simple as
possible so you don't get backed up
you're right you're right and i'm trying
to relax things a little bit to speed
things up a little bit so okay yeah yeah
so we get out of that fine dining
mentality and sort of you know push it
forward okay you'll be surprised every
year how many tables you turn quicker
which we do we need to turn them
[Music]
the staff quickly preps the mashed
potatoes in an attempt to get back on
track and push entrees out
potatoes potatoes potatoes
please
as chris finds his groove the kitchen
catches up
and now for the first time this dining
room is turning tables she's gonna sit
you down and we do have a couple tables
getting up in here i promise as soon as
we get that plate we'll get you right
down three more salmon and crabs up
a macaroni we used to have nights where
we would do 30 dinners and it felt like
85. everything's looking good guys
beautiful it's the relaunch we did 85 it
felt like doing 30. it was a nice change
i got to say all right pick up please
it's just going to take chris a little
while he's not really good with change i
mean think about it we've had the same
food
on the menu for almost four years now so
change is not a thing for chris are we
starting to play down or
yeah
with two dinner seatings completed the
new hannah and masons has successfully
cleared its first major
the hurdle was phenomenal the vibrance
the freshness and the feedback was great
however more importantly to this
restaurant is quality control her
special is to enlighten a customer to
what the chef's about
uh fair enough
you can make mash four potatoes peeled
bang
that's where we discipline ourselves
yeah you're right
uh
you're right i'm saying you're right
relax god
ryan
i want you
and him to be better don't understand i
want you up there
i'm not treading water down there i look
forward to the future and i just i still
think there's a lot that we need to work
out um chris and i so
you know there's still some more
changing to do and this is the start so
we're excited i came here because you
asked me to come here you had to put
this restroom back on the map
yeah the minute i've gone yeah it's up
to you guys
but one thing you have to do is make
money to survive
that means commitment
heart desire and the real hunger to make
it work
i give you a new menu
new decor new equipment new launch what
i cannot give you
is the heart
to make this successful that can only
come
within and that's what it's going to
take to get this place
pumping i think brian sees that he could
put his stamp on this place now as well
i think in the past he thought it was
only chris's place chris putting his
demon i think he he sees now it's a
clean slate and he can put his thumb
print on it call me yeah i will yeah
murray has your cell right she has my
email she has my cell yeah and she has
my home address one thing she hasn't got
is my [ __ ] hotel room key
right good night
yes
[Music]
good night guys thank you thank you take
care
that was tough honestly really tough
from the minute we had the valentine day
massacre to a successful re-launch
tonight it's been a tough week and i
personally feel that i've been dragging
nick brian and chris every inch of the
way and i don't know if they've got the
desire to go that extra mile but what i
do know is
these apples are delicious
you